people quit all the time because they're
doing it for the money there's a debate
right now going on Twitter of like how
many years do you have to work until the
hard work until the thing this guy's
like Gary you said you hustled your face
off for ten years he's like I only had
to do it for two years I couldn't
imagine doing it for ten and I'm
laughing at him and another guy jumps in
and goes well Gary said it best
eat [ __ ] for blank ears and eat caviar
for the rest of your life like are you
enjoying like is this fun and I'm sure
he's a lovely dude is this fun are you
filming this or are you doing it because
you think it's gonna get you to the next
level of success do you love your
process the Gateway to happiness is to
love your process whatever that may be
whether that's creates wealth or doesn't
if that creates legacy and art or
doesn't that creates impact in the world
or it doesn't
you're clearly driven like you know
first wanted to be in the FPA and I
wanted to be in a deep then you wanted
to be in the PBA then you wanted to act
like I think I think the thing that you
need to understand is that you've got a
gear of motivation that makes you do the
first two things in sports didn't work
out the thing that worked out and acting
it did worked out whatever the
definition of what you're trying to
figure out right now it may or may not
work what I'm excited about is the fact
that you've got a gear that makes you
want to do I think one of the biggest
problems right now especially for people
under 30 who want to be influencers or
entrepreneurs which is almost everybody
there's a lot of vanity metrics that
they're trying to achieve to that mean
nothing I raised fifty million dollars
so you might go out of business I've got
a million subscribers so I've got to
hunt ten million subscribers so I think
I think right now you know we live in a
world that has so much data that people
are living towards the numbers how many
likes how many followers how much
capital have raised it it's a it becomes
a numbers racket race and it usually
leads to bad behavior because when
you're chasing a number that people can
see you often take shortcuts for me the
[ __ ] is the cabbie
like I love the [ __ ] process I love
building a very big reason acting
probably looked out was you both thought
it could bring you something you were
looking for from the level of attention
and success and fame and dollars but you
also liked it because otherwise if you
didn't like it you would have quit after
the third no at officience when you do
something for money you quit when you do
it because you love it you do it forever
people win when they're self-aware some
want to make their bed some don't some
have this strength some have that
weakness you need to figure out who you
are and you need to execute against that
you have to love the process not the
stuff that the process buys you people
quit all the time because they're doing
it for the money I think the bigger
question is what do you want the money
for is it blocking and insecurities if
you get the girl is it is it it's
because you're trying to amass as much
as you can because you don't actually
don't like working and you want to live
a the reason so many people say fail in
life and business is their model is let
me get the money so that I can enjoy and
relax they think of it as like hoarding
it and then eating it all over time so
our retirement and uh listen it's such a
bad way to because then you're feeling
the pressure of like massing so that you
can then enjoy I think the bigger
question is like what do you up to like
why are you doing it like what's up I
just think a lot of people are trying to
achieve success and use fame or money as
makeup for
a situation that they're just not happy
about like you have to figure out how to
make your day in and day out happy it's
all an inside game you need to be
enjoying the amassing so much that you
never get to the enjoying part otherwise
you're gonna be impatient and trying to
be out of it as quickly as possible to
buy those things or you're gonna regret
it later in life right like I will never
retire because it's not as fun as
working like it's not as fun like it's
very it's not as fun for me to lay on
the beach and play golf all day and and
and lay on a yacht in the middle of the
Mediterranean for a hundred days in the
summer and go to vineyards and go to
concerts and and see friends that's not
as fun as [ __ ] 15 hours of meetings
all day I don't want to lay in Aswan in
a pool I don't want to that is what
people have to figure out whether that's
singing or being a mother or teaching a
classroom to me the game matters and by
life somebody may be looking and being
like Gary looks like [ __ ] 4 a.m. 6
flights and Asia and I'm sitting here in
Ibiza and for her or him that's winning
and that's great you've got to try and
figure that out at all costs that if
you're not happy right now you need to
do something different I just I just
don't understand how people think wealth
is the gateway to happiness
the Gateway to happiness is to love your
process whatever that may be
whether that's creates wealth or doesn't
if that creates legacy in art or doesn't
that creates impact on the world or it
doesn't you've got it you've got to try
and figure that out at all costs that if
you're not happy right now
you need to do something different you
just have to be if you are not happy
right now you have to break your
patterns you have to look at life from a
different perspective
you have to find a different angle to
look at it from because the [ __ ] goes
fast if you know it's long figure out
what your [ __ ] winning is my winning
is different than a lot of people's I
don't get envy I get excited I get
competitive I enjoy it I join my thing
what's your thing that makes you the
happiest may just focus there only there
you
[Music]